a racist display at a henderson shopping
mall shocking many in the community mary
jane bellies joining us live from the
galleria to explain the outrage mary
tayne
heather good afternoon to you community
leaders filled the galleria mall parking
lot this morning to protest a racist
display that was up for several weeks
stating racism is not welcomed in our
community the national action network
and other civil rights organizations are
outraged the network is reporting the
racist display was shown in front of
families and children from may 30 to
july 5th the display by las vegas
railway society shows a black man being
prepared to be hung robert bush the
local president of the national action
network says the goal of monday's
protest is to show the community that
racism will not be tolerated and they
are demanding an apology
not only was it racist but but there are
better ways
to depict black people in their history
of the railways such as blacks were the
first porters such as blacks built most
of the railways throughout the united
states if they wanted to show history in
the united states then there was a much
better way to be able to do that than
than a racist display
galleria mall general manager did offer
an apology bush tells me the las vegas
railway society has not yet responded
initially this was reported to the las
vegas action network through email that
display was taken down last week
reporting from sunset and stephanie
street mary jane balleza live local now
mary jane thank